et c'est un véritable scandale de santé
aux états unis un homme s'est vu refuser
une greffe de coeur car non vaccinés un
sujet qui relance le débat donc de la
vaccination là bas aussi et qui continue
de diviser les américains valentin
carpentier
il fait la une des journaux américains
dj ferguson a 31 ans et souffre d'un
problème cardiaque héréditaire
hospitalisé à boston depuis le 26
novembre dernier le père de famille a
été retiré de la liste des personnes
éligibles à une greffe de coeur premiers
de cette liste du brigham and women's
hospital il ya encore quelques semaines
le patient n'est plus éligible à
l'opération car non vaccinés contre le
coc vie 19 une situation alarmante pour
sa famille
annie fils a frôlé la mort pour défendre
ses convictions
son coeur s'est tellement détériorée
qu'il ne fonctionne plus de lui-même
interrogé l'hôpital n'a pas tenu à
commenter davantage la situation du
patient mais c'est justifié via un
communiqué pour l'établissement sa non
vaccination pas ce problème car elle
l'optimiste pas la survie du patient
d'autant plus que le pays connaît une
pénurie d'organes la grippe peut vous
tuer un recul que vous tuez le coc vide
peut vous tuer les organes son bar et
ils ne vont pas les distribuer à
quelqu'un qui a peu de chance de vivre
alors que d'autres personnes vaccinées
ont de meilleures chances après
l'opération après une transplantation
he a un coeur peu importe votre système
immunitaire est à l'arrêt
un fait divers qui relance le débat de
la vaccination aux états unis si joe
biden tente de l'imposer dans l'ensemble
du pays il doit faire face à une forte
résistance
le gouvernement américain a d'ailleurs
dû retirer ce mardi l'obligation de
vaccination dans les entreprises de plus
de 100 employés suite au veto émis par
la cour suprême
et les cas comme dj ferguson contribuer
à la division et ce n'est pas une
première il y a déjà quelques semaines
des médecins d'un hôpital du minnesota
ont tenté de retirer le respirateur
d'une personne également non ciné